mama darf
ich jetzt bekommen heißen 2. Teil von
wer lügt besser
habe ich den Haarreifen hier
die man an dem
habe ich
[Musik]
Flash in den Tisch
greifen
ja sag doch
[Gelächter]
und zwar habe ich ihr ein Antistress
Roller
ich weiß nicht was das ist ja
ist das dieses Ding was man sich über
die Haut rollt ok über den Boden
ich habe ja ein Produkt eine Zunge
Flash mal die Zoo
kannst du mal deinen ziehen
mache ich nein richtig ich kenne die
Zunge ich ziehe dann irgendwann haben
ich glaube dir
zeig mir die Zunge
kannst du mal wieder zu
viel mal auf
und sag mal in die Kamera irgendwas
cooles
ja du hast eine Sonnenbrille nein
nein
als nächstes ein Furzkissen
jetzt ausgeschaltet ein Furzkissen kann
nicht ausgeschaltet sein doch es ist
ausgeschaltet ja darauf
ja ich muss dann machen
nein das furzt bringst du furzen
[Applaus]
ich glaube
ich
habe in der Hand eine Fake Wimper
nein du Kacke getrickst
wenn ich Geld habe oder dann wenn die so
aufgeklebt wo er sich Aussehen madonna
ich glaube es ist kein Dollar Ding
sondern also ich kann was steht da drauf
[Musik]
ich glaube dir
ich habe hier eine Socke
[Musik]
was ist auf der Socke die ist einfach
schwarz eine schwarze Socke
krempelt ihm herum
[Musik]
schick sie mal im Mund
war
ja nee du willst nicht mehr zu zocken
Mutter
ich habe hier eine Waffe
[Musik]
wie soll ich denn drücken
es wäre echte Waffe ich kann Dir
beweisen
ich habe hier eine
[Musik]
ja warte doch bitte
ja
okay hast du
was ist von Star Wars
Sandra stinkt
Laserschwert
[Applaus]
ist
eine Wimpernzange
das sind schwierige Sachen
[Musik]
Gedanke nicht verletzen. Entscheide ich
habe gesagt ich habe gesendet ich habe
gewonnen